et les César de l'admiratrice est
attribué à
Virginie Efira
[Applaudissements]
de Serge Bozon les enfants des autres
pièces de tolski et donc revoir Paris au
cours avec comme partenaire Benoît
Magimel elle avait déjà été nommée à 4
prises comme meilleures actrices c'est
ce soir son tout premier César
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop chouette
en même temps j'ai fait 63 films cette
année donc arithmétiquement je mettais
un peu donner les chances je sais qu'on
a peu de temps mais je voudrais d'abord
rendre hommage non pas David Fincher ça
c'est déjà fait quoi que ce qui nous
passionne comme spectateur ben constitue
aussi notre travail mais rendre hommage
aux actrices avec qui je suis nommée à
Fanny Ardant Juliette Binoche qui
convoque parmi les plus belles images de
cinéma de lors de celle qui ne
s'effaceront jamais leur calami pour la
puissance
vivifiante de son jeu et Adèle
exarcopoulos mon ami dont les choix
l'authenticité l'audace m'éblouissent
fortement ensuite ce César il est pour
où es-tu Alice Vigneau cours où sont les
resatrices Alice il est pour toi il est
pour revoir Paris merci pour ce
personnage pour ce film juste beau
consolateur cathartique d'avoir laissé
cette place là aux victimes là on va
rendu hommage merci infiniment merci aux
productrices au distributeur à l'équipe
du film à mes partenaires et je vais
étendre de César aux autres
réalisatrices arbécasse zottowski merci
pour les enfants des autres
merci pour ce personnage
et pour ce tournage merveilleux merci
Anne merci Catherine merci Marion et
manuel et merci
une
trio commence et tout s'ouvre pour moi
merci Nil Florent Grégoire merci Ali
sans toi ce serait vachement moins
joyeux merci beaucoup ça me fait
infiniment plaisir
[Applaudissements]